I ever put a person's images up on the
view box early in the consult I really
try and understand the person who they
are their personality and and then I I
assess them further physical pain
triggers and only then will I look at
the images and when I looked at the
images I was quite horrified he'd split
his sacrum front to back
l5 was heavily fractured and the disks
were if I used the word obliterated that
would be quite accurate so we started to
talk and he was starting to move a
little bit better and but he had to
humble himself right back to getting the
movement patterns right and some very
very basic patterns athletic patterns
and then he said in our conversation he
said well do you think I'm gonna get out
of pain because the surgeons I've I've
said seen that they said I'm done I'm
not even gonna get out of pain I've done
so much damage to my back and I said
well I don't know but let's let's that
here's my best effort and my best
suggestion on what to do well believe it
or not he was out of pain in about three
weeks just learning how to avoid the the
triggers but he said something very
curious to me he said well I'm gonna get
out of pain and when I get out of pain
I want my world record back and I said
to him I said well and obviously I'm a
lot older than he was and I said well if
you were my son Bryan I'd give you this
advice I said let's work on getting you
out of pain but I I would seriously
consider doing something else with your
life I mean that this is a pretty
compromise spine to build you back to
set a world record again this but he
said no I want to do that and I said
alright well if we do it we'll write a
book together so that was the story
behind the book called gift of injury
ladies and gentlemen welcome back this
episode is brought to you by the protein
works I'm very happy to be supported by
them again for this episode
they're giving away over a hundred
pounds of supplements this week and all
that you need to do to enter is share
this episode I'm absolutely certain it's
going to be a massive help to a lot of
people so find a friend that you think
would be interested fire it in a group
chat or feel free to post it on your
social all you need to do is then send
me a screenshot at Criswell x on
whatever social media you want find me a
screenshot or tag me in your share and I
will pick someone over the next week and
I'll announce that before next Monday
but on to today's guest dr. stuart
mcgill we are getting fully spinal today
aren't we
how are you welcome to the show well I'm
well Chris how about you I'm fantastic
thank you I've been looking forward to
this episode for as long as I can
remember posted it in the gym Facebook
group asking if they had any questions
so we've got crowd-sourced questions
about spinal health is gonna be a good
one today so first off I guess I posted
in the group perfect example posting the
group and a lot of people had questions
why is it that for people who take care
of the health and fitness spines are so
problematic well I could go so many ways
with that question but I think it's
because it's so difficult to do things
without a robust back think of all the
things we do they all involve the back
so I I guess that's why they're they're
problematic but I can be a bit more
specific and that is if we
subcategorized spines and people we
would converge on common patterns and if
we did a little bit of pattern
recognition we'd notice some real cause
and effect for example athletic groups
are really fun to study there are
certain leads in sport where they just
clearly have an under
performing core they spend a lot of time
on other parts of their body but the the
demands on their spines simply outpace
the foundation that they've built and
they end up with either injury or pain
or compromised performance or any of
those but in the general public why our
spines so problematic look at our lives
you know I started as a professor 34
years ago computers weren't even
invented yet we would spend time walking
down halls meeting with our colleagues
and and doing our clinic work in our lab
work within those 32 years something
happened I became a computer operator
students no longer wanted to come to
office hours they would send an email
and I'd say I don't do emails which he
better come and we'll have some hands-on
but you know it was just I became a
computer operator now that is you know I
had a good back but sitting all day gave
me back pain so this is why I think it's
problematic to use your words and then
the solution became well now you've
become a slave to your chair and your
computer for eight or ten hours now
you're going to blow out all of the
stress one hour at the gym
so let's compound the biological
perturbation here and people would start
treating their spinal joints because
they were locked up all day at the
computer like ball and socket joints but
they're not biologically they're an
adaptable fabric made of collagen
strands held together with a ground
substance and they follow different
rules so you know there's all kinds of
other downsides to sitting a lot your
hips get stiff well mobile powerful hips
are one of the secrets of skillful
athletic
performance and spine sparing strategies
so are our people undoing the chronic
adaptations and stress in their hips
when they go to the gym sometimes they
do the opposite
I guess the final bit and and this is
coming a bit randomly in in a thought
pattern between my ears
very few people these days get a
competent and thorough assessment of the
mechanism of their back pain so they
willy-nilly try untargeted therapies and
their spines remain problematic too to
really answer your question so if a
person has a back issue and they have a
thorough competent assessment so they
understand very precisely what the pain
trigger or mechanism is they then have a
roadmap to guide a strategy to remove
the cause and secondly to build a
foundation to be pain-free and this
functional and and fit as they want to
be so it's a bit of a long-winded answer
but those are some random thoughts as to
why spines are problematic well I guess
first and foremost spines are a complex
system right there's a lot going on with
your spine it runs for a lot of your
body there's a lot of interactions going
on there so it wouldn't ever be a single
a single answer one of the things
definitely one of the questions I've got
down what your views on workplace
ergonomics you know you've already
touched on it the the sedentary nature
of us being Sat is it simply that we're
sat for a long period of time or is it
that we're stationary is a standing desk
a solution for this what what your
thoughts on the ergonomics of workplaces
well I have several thoughts I wrote a
an opinion piece quite a number of years
ago for the journal called ergonomics
and think of the office where you can
organize it in a way to reduce stress
you can adjust heights the way you sit
and these kinds of things but then I
would say well is there such a thing as
an ideal posture and I think we would
both converge that no there isn't the
ideal posture is one that frequently
changes because you migrate stress
concentrations in your body through
posture change so that that's a little
bit of a myth there are many jobs by the
way that he can't do organ ah mcc's with
can you imagine a farmer a forester a
fisherman the lumber Ivan a bus driver a
miner very few can do ergonomics all
they have is the skill to move their
body in ways that do not create stress
concentrations to the point of pain so I
ergonomics is limited in in in many jobs
for sure and even some of the
foundational principles of ergonomics
may not be appropriate for certain
people in certain jobs in that there is
no ideal the ideal is is a moving target
and that's just the biological reality
of it if you were to prescribe a cadence
of movement from seating to standing or
from if someone was to potentially be
able to do their work what let's say
they were able to do some calls they
were able to walk while they were on a
call perhaps with a hands-free kit or
something like that is moving as
frequently as possible whilst obviously
not completely degrading here ability to
do the work on your laptop or your or
your computer is that optimal is it to
move as much as possible and vary the
vary the posture well you're on the
right track no I would I think you've
gone from one stream extreme to the
other saying move as much as possible
but I would say move more absolutely so
as great cook who many of your listeners
will know I think he coined the phrase
move well and moved often and there's a
lot of wisdom to that now what is
optimal will be very specific to the
person for sure their age their past
injury history all of these factors so
there's no note there's no substance
you've got to get up out of the chair
and move for you think of every system
in the body and every single one of them
thrives on movement for optimal health
but that optimum is between not too much
and not too little
so moving as often as possible you're
going to need to sit down to have a rest
a few but you know what I mean but
biology has a tipping point and there's
such a thing as too much just as there's
such a thing as too little the trick of
it all is to find that medium totally I
certainly can appreciate and as you were
saying earlier on the reason that I
laughed at when you were talking about
people trying to offset a sedentary work
lifestyle with intense training is that
that is the avatar of the person that I
was for for quite a while I presumed
that a step counter was really the only
only for like my mom my dad like I don't
need to bother myself with a step
counter because I'm going into the gym
and I'm knocking out a thousand calorie
fifteen hundred calorie session in you
know between an hour and two hours five
six times a week and you know I'll do a
little bit of foam rolling before I
start and nut that like I don't need to
bother about that like that will undo my
any issues and at the beginning of last
year I had quite a bit of bad back pain
which I'm still rehabbing through at the
moment and an MRI at the beginning of
this year showed two bulging discs in l5
s1 and a smalls node that you know what
caused that it has a very precise cause
please elaborate well as schmorl's nodes
you weren't born with it you you
developed it now schmorl's node is
consider the vertebra as a barrel so the
side of the barrel is cortical bone and
the top and bottom of the barrel that
interfaces with the disc is a
cartilaginous plate that's called the
end plate when you lift heavy and you
exceed your biological tolerance
that end plate bulges and it will get a
little crater that forms in it it's
actually a fracture and that's caused by
very high pressure in the nucleus which
comes from lifting heavy so at some
point you lifted heavy to the point
where you created that small fracture
now I've had two of them in in my life
one was hardly noticeable and the other
one was quite to symptomatic for a
couple of years but then what happens is
the disk loses a little bit of height
now you can imagine letting a little bit
of air out of your car tire the tire
then starts to bulge a little bit and it
gets a bit sloppy on the road that's
exactly what happens to that joint in
the spine now you lose a little bit of
height and if you keep bending the
collagen is no longer
turgid that forms the disk it's not a
ball and socket joint it's actually
strands of college and kind of glued
together to it basically it's a
biological goo now that goo can be
adapted to be softer which will allow
you to have a lot more mobility like say
if you did a lot of yoga or you exposed
your back to high loads without a lot of
mobility that goo actually gets more
gooey and if you believe in well I have
to squat as deeply as possible and that
kind of thing and you have a little butt
link at the bottom it now becomes a bit
more problematic following that
schmorl's node or that end plate
fracture and the collagen will keep
adapting to that deep squat mobility
bike becoming a less gooey shall we say
in in the ground substance it will
dilemma Nate and then you will get a
disc bulge so it's a combination of
loaded flexion and it's accelerated by
lifting too heavy in the first place so
quite often it starts off with a heavy
deadlift and then goes on to repeated
loaded flexion how close am I on that
pretty pretty damn close I was good
hang on oh my god I was gonna ask you
another question I've not told you about
my training history if I was to present
you with the particular symptoms that
I've just explained to you now what
method what methodology would you
predict that I'm following CrossFit 100%
right yeah I know I see them all the
time so I read I read and I will be
linking in the show notes below an
article the article such interview that
you did with tee nation yeah and it was
on the I guess that common injuries that
are associated with CrossFit and a
biomechanical breakdown of that there
will be a lot of CrossFitters who will
be listening there will also be some
some power lifters some weight lifters
and some endurance athletes as well but
right I would be interested to hear if
you could give a an explanation of what
are the typical injuries and why that
you see them with CrossFit your
assessment of the injury to methodology
relationship
yeah well it's a fabulous question but
injuries cluster around specific for
sports and specific training methods and
there's a reason for it it's the chronic
exposure so physical exposure to the
body causes adaptations now that up to
adaptation can be good or it can be bad
but you load the body and the body will
adapt so that's the beginning opening
principle if you go back to that T
nation article I I think it was in the
title of the first paragraph I have a
love-hate relationship with CrossFit I
mean I absolutely love CrossFit for the
culture for the supportive community I
love it I if I was younger I would have
been in there a hundred percent but now
let's get into the biological adaptation
and then I can give you a solution so
CrossFit combines adaptations to
stimulate mobility and then the next
exercise is asking you to have a tougher
call
halogen let me give you an example so if
you start out a routine with 10 burpees
you are creating a high mobility in the
back without much load so burpees on
their own are probably not going to
create too much challenge to the
adaptation process you're teaching the
spine to be a bit more mobile but it
doesn't pay the price because there's no
load then the next routine is repeated
Olympic lifts now we have a problem
there's no margin for bad form so
CrossFit tries to create an endurable
athlete a power athlete and a mobile
athlete that's very very difficult to do
in terms of biological adaptations so by
programming 10 Olympic lifts you know
the form is going to deteriorate
now you're migrating stress the first
two reps might be alright and and
interestingly enough I don't get many
Olympic lifters in as back pain patients
they have to go and see the knee and
shoulder guys those are the joints that
the Olympic lifters are having trouble
with not really that they've got quite
healthy low backs as very stiff
well they lock them into much more of a
neutral position because the mobility is
at the the hips and they're actually a
speed power athlete they're very very
quick they have good pulsing on and off
they they relax to catch the bar in the
snatch and all of these kinds of things
but let's get back to the CrossFit
programming the first two lifts might be
fine the third one now you're starting
to get a little bit tired you're
polluting the perfect movement muscle
memory of an Olympic lifts so do you see
to be a great Olympic lifter you would
never pollute it when you're tired but
CrossFit's a different sport it is an
endurance and look I get the sport you
know there's lots of sports that that
aren't necessarily the best for your
long-term athleticism that's
you know I have a lot of MMA athletes I
don't think that's a particularly
healthy thing to do for your body but
it's a sport nonetheless when they come
to me asking for help so of course I get
CrossFit athletes as well and it's my
job to try and adapt their body to be
resilient but we have to make a
compromise here but that's the nature of
the programming so somewhere you have to
be between stiffening the spine collagen
through a repeated load exposures heavy
load exposures but you can't move your
back you know that that's the difference
so on rep one and two you might be fine
on the Olympic lifts but rep eight nine
and ten are pretty nice in terms of the
bending stresses and it's at that point
where things fall off the rails in terms
of biological adaptations and the
collagen starts to the fibers not the
fibers necessarily but the ground
substance but between them start to
loosen up and the fact of the matter is
the nucleus will slowly work its way
through the dominating collagen and get
a disc bulge so every sport has its
[Music]
pattern shall we say and that certainly
is now if I could offer this and and I
think in that article I I did offer a
solution at the end and it comes from
let's take the good things from CrossFit
and mitigate the things that are not so
good in terms of biological adaptation
and Dan John if you have you ever heard
of Dan John out of the u.s. they call
him the the quirky uncle or something of
training he's a fabulous fella we're
both the same age we're both in our
middle sixties we we have somewhat of
the same background and whatnot
but Dan is a really wise guy and he's
he's very clever in that he can say
things in just a few words but Dan's
solution to the Burpee Olympic lifts
routine would be to do kettlebell swings
with a goblet squat for example so there
would be a wonderful substitute in a
CrossFit program to mitigate the
biological adaptations that are going to
lead to tissue breakdown isn't that it
isn't that an interesting one to think
about so from a biological adaptation
point of view both of those involve a
hip hinge they involve strength
endurance and they're telling the body
to adapt in a consistent way which is
not so with burpees and Olympic lifts
anyway there there's just a thought for
you but you mentioned other athletes as
well like power lifters for example they
have a slightly different cluster of
patterns for back injury but generally
speaking they to begin with end plate
fractures and schmorl's nodes but here's
the difference
let's take bodybuilding where you train
on Monday to tear down muscle at the
micro-level
Tuesday you rebuild the muscle in the
kitchen and in bed in other words while
you're resting and Wednesday you go
again and you repeat the process power
lifters when you examine and I worked
with some of the grand old women and
grand old men of powerlifting the very
successful ones you the CrossFitters
would consider them under trained
because a very heavy strong power lifter
might do heavy squats on mondays and
take five days off in other words they
allowed all the microfracturing at the
this is at the micro level now down at
the level of the bone osteons or the
bone cells they are damaged there's no
question but is that damn
a good thing or a bad thing for a
crossfitter it would be a bad thing
because the crossfitter says Oh on my
day off I only ran 5k wait a second
that's not a day off that's more
cumulative so it's crazy to keep
stimulating the body to adapt and then
you know you don't take the day off to
allow the adaptation but the powerlifter
has a much more wise biological
adaptation schedule they'll do heavy
squats or or say it's a pull from the
from the ground a deadlift for example
and then they take five days off now
let's discuss the adaptation of bone
bone is a piezoelectric material and
what that means is when you stress a
bone it builds an electric charge that
electric charge attracts free ions of
calcium and magnesium and it blues it or
chemically bonds it to where the
fracture is or the high stress but it
takes five days for those new ions of
basic bone building material calcium
magnesium and whatnot to scaffold on
before they break it off again but what
is the crossfitter do they train the
next day and they break off the
adaptation that they were trying to
create so do you see the the same micro
damage in a powerlifter is a good thing
it stimulated adaptation but they were
wise enough to let the biology over the
next five days really build substantial
bone strength that's not typically the
way a crossfitter would train it's just
more is better and they don't allow
sufficient adaptation so these are all
very interesting philosophical things to
discuss in terms of creating robustness
to load and better athletic performance
but you know I I get it I get CrossFit I
get why you do it as I said I would have
been there if it was 40 years ago as
well however I've learned quite a bit
about biology in the meantime and that's
why
these the the training you know it may
not be so much the the poor exercises
sometimes it may just be the not paying
enough attention to the adaptation
schedules of some of these things and
you know that's just pure programming so
any organization could change their
programming and create a more robust
athlete
I think this certainly in the CrossFit
community there is a addiction to
training the classes would tend to run
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday off
Friday Saturday Sunday off which means
that you're going to be training even if
you're just like a rx class athlete or
even a scaled class athlete you're going
to be doing five days of training per
week now you're not going to be pushing
the same sort of loads in terms of
percentages frequently as a power lifter
but you're going to be doing an awful
lot and I I do I get what you mean
the the fact that a rest day for for
anyone who follows Zach George UK
athlete you'll see his active recovery
days that he does on a Thursday which
will be like a 40-minute Imam of rowing
wall balls and burpees and that's that's
his active recovery day but it'll be a
pace that would been any other normal
athlete it just happens to be that he's
a little bit of a freak
so yeah the the fact that that's
considered a rest day by CrossFit is is
um when you look at it in the cold light
of days and probably to other sports as
well especially power lifters but then
on the flip side from there kind of
cultural perspective CrossFit is look
across at the in our gym we have a cross
for area weightlifting area bodybuilding
area and powerlifting area so there's
like every different species of strength
athlete is kind of moving around and in
the same place and some endurance guys
as well and the CrossFit is will look
over at the power lifters and see that
they're sat down for five minutes in
between lifts and they'll they'll be
sort of thinking giving them [ __ ] and
then the power lift also be looking at
the CrossFit is wearing their brightly
colored shorts with like doing millions
of reps and burpees and going out and
running in the rain and stuff and
they'll be giving them a share and
it's it's interesting it's very in a
very interesting dynamic I think you
probably quite enjoy observing from a
bird's eye view if you could access the
CCTV yeah Chris that's my world I won't
send you the stream all right but I of
course I know exactly what you talked
about look my job is to try and
understand these mechanisms and then
when a person has pain mitigate them
it's so interesting you know years ago I
would see someone on the way to a back
injury and you know you're almost always
right not always but almost always right
and but I learned it's almost impossible
to motivate the uninjured so if they
haven't got back pain yet Who am I to go
over and and give them any advice
unfortunately we have to let them learn
the hard way and then all of a sudden
they're motivated to listen and
hopefully we can come up with something
that will address the the mechanism a
bit well I can put my hand in the air
and say that my rehab was the second
thought up until the point at which
rehab was all that I could do like when
I was still able to Train rehab took a
back seat and last year when my back
went want of a better term that was when
I decided to really pay a lot of
attention to my rehab now I did but then
over the space of a month last summer
flew for 60 hours did a powerlifting me
in Hawaii went and trained CrossFit with
Michael cashew in Texas and then came
back to the UK and just started all over
again
and the same thing happened I've been
sat on planes cramped up rattled up into
all manner of different different
postures and then the same the same
thing happened again so so you earned
your pain I have yeah I really did I
mean it's one of those things another
interesting point on that in terms of
the injury giving
people the motivation to do the rehab
was when I had an MRI scan at the
beginning of this year so I've been
working after back end of last year sort
of five months or so working quite hard
on my rehab but was seeing an upper
limit in terms of my recovery I then saw
the MRI scan this year now I know that
there is a very tenuous link between
pathologies that present on scans and
pain that presents a lot of people who
do strength sports would present some
sort of abnormality if you were to show
them an MRI but many of them may not
have pain and some people with pain may
not present on an MRI but for me to see
the fact that there was something
actually there it wasn't just pain this
kind of nebulous weird ephemeral thing
in the back of my mind to see that there
was something actually there that had
been caused that was the cause of my
pain and also the cause of my the adieu
to my training that really hit home and
the last few months have really stepped
up how much I've taken care how
consistent I've been with the big three
and a bunch of other things as well it's
the MRI was a real kind of like whoa
moment well MRIs if they're used
properly are absolutely fabulous in uric
you're a case in point
when and I argue this statement that MRI
evidence does not link to pain in fact I
would argue the opposite the problem is
an MRI image shows Anatomy and I don't
know how old you are but say you're
thirty good thirty thirty-one yeah you
can't fool me Stu knows but anyway if
what I'm looking at on your MRI is
thirty one years of life now
some of the features that are on the MRI
are old wounds
sorry old scars they don't cause pain
anymore some of them will be fresh
wounds now a radiologist has no way of
knowing which are wounds and which are
scars what is painful and what is not
however if you proceed the MRI session
with a thorough assessment of the person
you know exactly what you're going to
see on the EMR so you can do a thorough
assessment and you know the pain is
coming from whatever structures and
plates you know compromise nerve roots
sacroiliac joints or whatever the
assessment will reveal those sources and
then you go look at the MRI scans and
you'll get pretty close to a one-to-one
match so I wouldn't blame the MRIs of
not being linked to pain it's the system
that prevents them from being linked to
pain so they become quite powerful after
you've already seen the person but
here's the thing
the radiologist has no idea whether that
person is a crossfitter a powerlifter
or a sedentary worker at a 10 hour a day
computer job and what i mean by that is
i i've seen athletes who bring in their
MRI reports and the report says oh
they've got degenerative disc disease
and then I look at the MRIs and I say
that's a that's a powerlifter spine
that's not an EM are that those are
sclerotic endplates that's what that's
the bony callus that an that a
powerlifter has developed and adapted
over 20 years of heavy lifting but the
but the radiologist had no idea whether
that was an adaptation to heavy exposure
so now that's healthy that's exactly
what the power lifted needed to set a
world record yeah so so do you see my
issue when I hear that MRIs are not
linked it's the system that and and the
fact that radiology I don't think
radiologists should be allowed to write
a report they've never seen the person
so they have no context now they're good
at looking for cancer as tumors and
things like that but in the world of
back pain that's extremely rare so to
link it to physicality you've got to
know the person first and then we can
interpret the MRIs and they can be very
helpful for people who
are a bit stubborn in the in the
response to two therapies so I mean
you're a perfect case in point I mean
these people who argue oh it's a psycho
psycho psychological issue that people
will start to obsess over their MRI wait
a second
you just gave an example of you just got
psychological relief in understanding
that you do have something there it's
not something to ignore it's time to get
on it and treat it and get your health
back so it all boils down to just being
a good human being and telling the truth
respecting that the patient you're
dealing with is not a five-year-old
there are 31 year old athlete who needs
to know a strategy to get rid of their
pain and get back to what they love
which is training CrossFit with with
their friends and I get at 100% yeah I
mean you totally correct I was in the
gym today watching some of the guys
throw down doing a class workout doing a
competition qualifier and I'm thinking
ah like I wish that I wish that I could
go back in there and do that but
previously before the MRI I'd have
probably been like oh well my back feels
okay today like oh boy can I just join
in and then that would be me
throw like I'll just go no no it's fine
like it my back it'll just be a thing
but then you're right the MRI really hit
home with regards to the fact no no no
hang on like your spine is something
that you're going to need for more than
just satiating the CrossFit hunger for
the next however long that's your
methodology it's something that you're
going to have to have functioning
effectively for the rest of your life so
take some time folks on the rehab and
work on that and then slowly begin to
build things back in which is currently
now the strategy and husband has been
for a while and it's working I take it
so it is specifically I won't bore the
listeners with my particular pathology
in my back there's some there's some
oddities that I I can't quite work out
and perhaps once I we get off the call I
might be able to explain them to you but
yeah there's some this
interesting things however since I've
focused a lot more since I've taken more
care about it I have seen a the plateau
that I spoke about before the MRI has
now been pushed through and the only
real thing which has changed has been
compliance with the rehab plan yeah what
people don't realize is just because the
pain is gone one day it doesn't mean
their back is healed and this is the
mistake the underlying adaptations still
need to continue to build that
robustness back again so if you've got a
disc bulge it's time to get the loss of
stiffness back into the disc with
stabilization exercise and whatnot and
the that's I hate that word because it
doesn't mention what specific exercises
they should be but nonetheless you do
have to honor that history because you
know there's some physical therapists
these days who say oh well just because
you have a back pain there's no evidence
of tissue damage and again I would argue
very vehemently against the opposite I
see the damage and I've created it in
the in the clinic and laboratory and we
document it and we know what to look for
most radiologists have no idea what to
look for and whether they're looking at
wounds or scars so again just because
you're out of pain behave and organize a
proper adaptation schedule and really
enhance the chance for being successful
at gaining your athletic robustness once
again I got you so we've touched one of
the things that you come up with a lot
is the relationship between stiffness
and flexibility in the spine would it be
possible to have a yogi who's also a
powerlifter know
[Music]
see one of the interesting things is
this i spoke to dr. quinn henyk doctoral
physical therapy for juggernaut training
systems about a year ago and he was
talking about what he referred to as
mobility myths so we were going through
the typical tools and approaches that
people use that you see in a gym the
static stretching the death Eragon the
vibrating foam roller the dynamic
stretching PMF and all these different
things news talking about the mechanisms
that actually occur when when these
things happen but I certainly know that
in strength sports at least in the UK in
my my experience I see a lot of static
stretching there's a number of
subscription services that you can get
that focus exclusively on static
stretching as a way to enhance mobility
and to improve your range of motion but
it sounds like you potentially might be
doing more damage than good with
something like that
well that wasn't your question you asked
me could they be a power lift or an in
yoga
let me say why I said that and very
emphatically have you built a
world-champion power lifter no do you
know one with loose hamstrings yeah they
don't exist
so yeah I mean the the strongest power
lifter has to have tight hamstrings it's
non-negotiable so there you have it
now a power lifter needs to fight their
mobility to get down into a proper
deadlift pull there has to be elastic
tension in their body to assist the
muscles in in the pole if you're gonna
win the worlds so you know you can't
they wear elastic knee wraps elastic
suits to add even more stiffness to
allow even more elastic recoil so I mean
but we're going to for the extreme here
is that healthy or is that a great
athlete or is that what you want I mean
that's debatable but let's go to the
other end have you ever worked with a I
mean I've had Yogi's who are on the TV
teaching yoga yoga as patients I can't
really think of too many who are strong
in fact they can do wonderful squats
their bottom can go right down
and touch the ground but they have
difficulty doing the bodyweight squat to
stand back up again is that so
oh yeah now somewhere people want to be
in the middle you know Yogi's aren't out
there on the rugby field nor is the
power lifter so that rugby player
somewhere in the middle
the crossfitter has to be somewhere in
the middle and that's the expertise of
first of all the dumb luck of choosing
your parents and then being as clever as
you possibly can
in creating the right adaptation I mean
I'll ask you some other questions the
NBA championships are on right now you
see a lot of people dunking basketballs
do you think they have loose hamstrings
no I'm one I'm one of the few who've
measured them no they're tight they
bounce off Springs so you know you you
went to this dark place of saying oh
well they're stretching programs to
create more mobility be careful now go
through the great athletes you've
measured and tell me who has unlimited
mobility they don't they're elastic
athletes they're wound up Springs so you
know you can go through the spectrum
from the throwers to the golfers to the
tennis players through to the Olympic
weightlifters I'm talking about elastic
athletes here what a mistake it is to
stretch away that elastic athleticism
it's not the way it works is it a other
to counter to each other
you've got stretching and then you've
got progressive overload and you've got
loading and those two are they about as
antagonistic as you can get yeah you're
talking extremes um maybe in in in some
people but again my world is elite
athletes I have to tune the Machine I'm
tuning elasticity I'm tuning fascial
trains I'm tuning muscle pulses I would
be very judicious in whether or not we
would stretch them away with the stat
stretch so we might do a static stretch
say for a rower who now has a lot of
posterior annular disc stress they've
just done a rowing session in a boat or
on owner ERG and I would say good lay on
your tummy and just breathe now there is
a static stretch for a rower now I might
do a thoracic extension stretch to give
them more elasticity so they're sliding
up the slide on the seat on the boat
they go into compression and the catch
and then the hips and knees start to
extend and then their spine as they sit
tall gets a little bit of a whip as
their hips explode and really whomp you
can hear that elastic storage and
recovery in in the fastest boats so you
know look at the people who throw a
baseball 110 miles an hour are they
heavily mobile well they are
asymmetrically mobile on one side but
they have a hell of an elastic you know
the first elastic across their hips the
second one across the front of their
chest and the third one in their in
their wrists you put those three
elastics together and you can throw on
it in ten miles an hour if you don't and
then all you have is mobility you won't
throw a ball buried you know Yogi's who
can throw 110 miles an hour do you know
a power lifter who can throw 110 miles
an hour have you measured the great
golfers how strong are they I'm not sure
have you tried well I've measured them
how how much effort have you ever tried
to hit a golf ball a long way yes okay
you noticed it didn't go very far no
further when you don't try so when you
have a muscle pulse of about 40 to 50 to
60% that is the sweet spot for speed
because when a muscle contracts it
creates force it also creates stiffness
if I maximally contract my bicep I can't
punch you I've got to really boom I got
to let it go when I measure the guys who
hit the hardest in the MMA leaks like
the UFC for example do you think it's
the guys with a great big muscle
no they pushed their punches it's the
guy who can snap BAM that hits the
hardest so it's a neural priming of a
spring that is then released now we've
got a lot to talk about in terms of
optimal athleticism so let's be a little
bit careful now when we talk about
static stretching to enhance injury
resilience and athletic performance
because in the great athletes and I'm
and I'm not talking about duffer's here
I'm talking world-class people be very
careful with stretching if it's good
enough for them then it's it's
definitely good enough for us you
touched on a couple of interesting
sports they're baseball and and golf
specifically I've always wondered what
the physiology of an athlete who has
such a unique type of movement as their
flagship of what their what their
athleticism is built around are there
some odd abnormalities especially with
someone like a baseball pitcher they may
be less so than someone I guess who's an
arm wrestler that would only ever focus
on like a very very you see these arm
racers who have one huge arm that's much
bigger than the other one what's the
sort of structure that you would see on
on golfers and on baseball pitches and
people like that well first of all
they're highly asymmetric athletes so
they're not gonna pass a screen for
symmetry but but but nor would you want
them to yeah you know they're attuned
elastic asymmetric athlete I don't
really know what more you want me to say
on this I can give you all kinds of
tests I mean it's so interesting when we
look at the fascial linkage for example
through the arm down the right side of
the body to the psoas muscle for example
and how I can tighten the Sohus by
internally and externally rotating the
arm through the shoulder and you can
palpate the so
tendon can try beginning tight and then
releasing by doing this so there would
be an example of a highly-tuned thrower
for example who has a beautiful elastic
tuned Jane if you you you didn't have
that body type you you won't throw very
fast and if you didn't adapt it you
probably wouldn't throw very fast either
so you know it's a combination of things
and then there's all kinds of things
with lever ratios and tendon lengths and
all kinds of things I mean a sprinter
looks like a sprinter for a reason right
they have a lot of lordosis and they're
low back and you know you don't need
much calf muscle but you need a pre
turned pelvis to get the power
production and hip extension out the
back to run if you plant your foot ahead
of your pelvis you're actually slowing
down all the power has to be owed to the
extensor range of the foot behind the
the pelvis but by the same token they're
not in the UFC kicking people in the
head those the fighters have flat backs
because they have to pre turn their
pelvis to kick high so you know again we
can talk about all of these adaptations
and and what you get from your parents
and what makes a good athlete and how
you tune them but I'd be very careful
with discussions of stretching and all
understood I wonder I wanted to move on
to the big three there will be a lot of
people listening who are familiar with
them
you know I'd love to hear the story of
why those movements were chosen and what
the mechanisms are that they're actually
working on right well around it would
have been about 30 years ago we were
starting to create different back
injuries on cadavers in in the lab and
when you damage a disc you lose a little
bit of disc height
now there's micro movements occurring at
that joint now you can't see them on an
MRI for example because it's it's only
under die
Namek load that these things are created
but if a person says you know I've got
right-sided back pain and then a little
bit later my right heel goes on fire and
then later on in the day I get some left
buttock pain well there's an example
where the pain triggers are migrating
around the back and and radiating down
the legs it tells you that there's
little micro movements in the joint
that's not a stable pain in other words
from a single disc bulge that has the
same pattern that just shrinks and grows
so we were looking for ways to stiffen
out those micro movements and we
assessed all kinds of exercises but they
had to have several criterion number one
is they had to guarantee stability now
we were measuring spine stability so we
could measure which exercises created
spine stability and which were called
spine stabilizers but they really
weren't so we started out at that level
and then we chose exercises that had a
high-reward low-risk in other words
maximum stiffening stabilizing
controlling attributes but minimal spine
load so the exercises that kept bubbling
up to the top were the ones like the
bird dog the side plank and the curl up
so consider the bird dog you can do a
Roman chair extension if you like but
it's double the spine load so that
didn't fit sparing your back that's why
we backed off and went opposite arm
opposite leg then other advantages
started to emerge you know it's a
natural PMF pattern a cross pattern
across the back and then we would hold
for 10 seconds we learned that one
because you clamp down the capillary bed
in in the muscle and the muscle becomes
acidic quite quickly and you oxygenate
and rebalance the pH of the muscle just
by sweeping the floor with your hand and
knee after 10 seconds and out you go
again
so you know there were people say oh I
hold my bird dog 30 seconds I said great
I hope you enjoy the pain
it didn't it wasn't consistent with the
science so we just put layers and layers
of investigation and science to try and
come up with the best exercises for
guaranteeing stability in a spine
sparing way and then programming them in
a way to reduce the risk of being
unsuccessful then recently with athletes
a strange thing happened first of all
your listeners need to understand the
principle of proximal stability for
distal athleticism
so consider if I was to attack at
benchpress 200-kilo I can't but say I
could there's my benchpress muscle my
PEC major so distally to the shoulder
joint it flexes my arm around that's its
distal effect but it's proximal effect
if I just contract my PEC major
approximately it bends my ribcage
towards my shoulder joint
so one creates a push and the other
leaks it away you see the difference now
if I create proximal stiffness first i
hardened my core I stiffen my body
proximally now 100% of that muscle
activity goes to the push because I've
arrested the energy loss or the energy
leak if people want to call it that or
the eccentric contraction approximately
so now we had to create more proximal
stiffness so we took muy Thai fighters
and we trained them with the big three
and then we trained others well not we
didn't train any one group no
differently they were the control group
but again we converged and found that
once they create more proximal stiffness
they actually had a higher closing
velocity with their fists and foot four
arm strikes and hand strikes and they
hit harder so the more proximal
stiffness you have the faster you can
run cut and change direction the harder
you strike a bag that's instrumented for
example etc etc etc so when athletes say
you know you've heard a few
quite famous athletes recently say you
know I got my back better and I'm back
on the course or the the the arena
whatever it is because I worked on my
core and this idea of proximal stability
is it's not a myth it absolutely
unleashes faster tennis serves throws
punches kicks running speed directional
change etc guess what those three
exercises also bubbled up as as being
quite superior now they won't take you
to the Olympics that's for sure and then
we well that that was my my book
ultimate back fitness and performance to
write progressions that would then keep
the theme going of arresting
micro-movements proximal stiffness and
stiffening appropriately the flexible
rod of the spine for more load bearing
if that's what the athletes need anyway
those were put together for the sport
and for the athlete but that's where
those exercises came from and that's how
they worked through the evolution over
the past thirty years but as you know
they're just a small part of the whole
back pain puzzle yeah for sure one of
the things that I think is is
interesting when we talk about that is
that certainly for me I actually find an
immediate relief when I do the big three
right so it's not it's it's not just
that there is an overtime adaptation
that Jamie actually feels like there is
a some sort of relief to my lower back
discomfort when I do them yep which I
think's we want to ask you do you want
to know why I certainly do if there's
any money in the world for me to turn to
tell me why it's you let's well we
measured a residual neural stiffness so
when you do those exercises your brain
remembers them and your core stays a
little bit stiffer in some people that
lasts about 20 minutes and some people
that lasts up to two hours
why does it work on you it's because I
will bet you've got a little bit of not
only do you have a disc bulge if you
have an in plate fracture or a smalls
note you will have lost a little bit of
height on that joint now it's lost a bit
of height it's a little bit of sloppy
and you've got micro movements doing the
big three adds a neural stiffness to the
barrel of muscle around that joint
that's lost a bit of stiffness you're
arresting the micro movements and you
feel better
[Music]
yeah that's anyway that's that we've
measured that and you'll notice that's
why some athletes who play professional
football for example start every game
and every training it's with the big
three
that's that woman they are faster and
they're also or paint Brazil it's part
of their warmup yes absolutely now if I
can give you one more hint Chris since
you're getting a immediate relief and a
resilient period after doing the big
three do them twice a day do the
mid-morning do half the volume mid
morning and then the other half
mid-afternoon and that will give you two
periods of respite throughout the day
and accelerate your wind down of the
pain sensitivity you should read a book
called back mechanic this is all in back
mechanic by the way I have from our
coach I've got it from our coach it's
gonna take me a little bit of time to
get through but links to back mechanic
and all of Stuart's doctor McGill's
other books will be in the show notes
below if you are interested one of the
questions that I had in our members
group actually when I posted the fact
that I was going to speak to you in was
what's the progression on from the big
three I think someone had been doing
them for quite a while and was feeling
like they were topping out at the degree
of overload or the degree of hard work
that they were doing with them and they
wondered what was next
okay well the answer the question I need
a context for the person for example for
many people who just want no pain
optimal hell
play with their kids maybe around a golf
and a little bit of adult activity on
Friday night whatever if that's what
they want then they're done all they
need is the big three that is sufficient
there's this idea on the internet that
people need to keep striving for their
personal best etc a lot of people will
be shortening their athletic career by
keep trying to push push push so there
is a concept of sufficient athleticism
sufficient stability sufficient strength
sufficient mobility and that is where
their optimal health will lie
however it's not going to get you to the
peak of the CrossFit Games or the
Olympics or anything else so if I was
preparing the average fighter for a
three rounder in the UFC so that's five
minutes on one minute off that's your
work rest schedule I would then say
let's do stir the pot so they're doing
their feet are on the ground and their
elbows are on a gym ball and now they
stir through the elbows for five minutes
and they can have one minute off times
three so if you think you're ready for a
little progression there's a there's a
little bit of a calibration for you that
must be so uncomfortable that must be
absolutely torturous that don't give me
that you're a cross that's what you
that's what it's all about that that
doesn't say well I'm wait and see I will
post it in the members group and the the
guy who you asked the question I'll see
if he can do the five minutes five
minutes on moment it off times three oh
I've got plenty of other tortures for
you if you want but you know it's it's
interesting I have a an acquaintance
will call them who is a very very
successful person I'm sure if I reveal
this name most of your listeners would
know if the person I'm talking about
he says the measure
and the predictability of one's success
is how willing they're ah how willing
are they to tolerate to discomfort that
is in a nutshell what he says will
separate those anyway that I'm sure
there's other things as well but that
that would have been his and there's
there's CrossFit to it so do you see you
see why I love it and I hate it
yeah absolutely there's a quote in James
clears atomic habit it's a book which
came out this year James is a hobbit
expert I'm not sure if you've read it
yet but if you know if you haven't and
if you've got time to read some of
you're looking for a holiday read highly
recommended my favorite book of 2019
beautiful I had James on the podcast
about three months ago and he's he
really is the real deal you know and he
went and interviewed the coach of a one
of the Chinese weightlifting teams
coaches and he asked him the question
what makes the difference between the
guys who are good and the guys who
become the absolute best and the coaches
answer was that it is the people who can
put up with the boredom of doing the
same thing day in day out and what he
identified there was that I think a lot
of normal athletes like myself look at
someone like Matt Fraser or Adele
Beckham or whatever it might be and
think well that person must never get
bored their training must always be
fantastic for them Anthony Joshua you
seem he is the sort of person who's
quite forthcoming about his training
online his training Diaries and stuff
like that he seemed training a lot and
he think he must must just turn up to
training in a love it every single day
and the coach of this particular
weightlifting team said that's not the
case at all he's like there's days when
my athletes turn up and they don't want
to be there they don't want and they
don't want to have to do yet another set
of polls from blocks or whatever it
might be they won't have to do more back
extensions what they do and they go
through it and he said that the
difference is the person who is able to
turn up and follow the program and just
stick to the plan and grind through
those days I thought that was really
really into
testing and illuminating I agree I'm
glad I'm glad as well the other thing
that I really liked about that was that
it it put the power for someone to
change their athletic ability in their
hands it's like look if the best
cross-thread on the planet Matt Fraser
gets board training and he works through
it then it's exactly the same for you he
doesn't have some superhuman level of
motivation he just grits his teeth and
does the work I thought was nice yeah
yeah well I don't know Matt Fraser but
he has to be of that type there's no
option cloth I wanted you to tell the
listeners the story behind the gift of
injury if you could well I was a book
it's co-authored by Brian Carroll so the
story is this I knew the name Brian
Carroll I'd never met him but he held
several records in powerlifting you know
he'd squatted well over 1,100 pounds
he'd squatted over a thousand pounds
over 50 times in international
competitions so he'd been around the
block so I knew the name and I knew some
of those statistics I got a phone call
one day and he was he said very politely
this is Brian Carroll a professor I've
hurt my back would you see me and I said
well yes and he came up and he was not
moving well and I thought wow this is
one of the best squatters and he has
difficulty getting getting in and out of
a chair and it seemed as though he lost
his discipline anyway within not too
long within an hour I would say he was
starting to move without triggering his
back pain and I said oh and then I I
never put a person's images up on the
view box early in the consult I really
try and understand the person who they
are their personality and and then I I
assess them further physical pain
triggers and
only then will I look at the images and
when I looked at the images I was quite
horrified he'd split his sacrum front to
back
l5 was heavily fractured and the discs
were if I used the word obliterated that
would be quite accurate now what does
that look like on an MRI is it just well
if you get the book you'll see because
we put that image that that MRI in the
book anyway so we started to talk and he
was starting to move a little bit better
and but he had to humble himself right
back to getting the movement patterns
right and some very very basic patterns
athletic patterns and then he said in
our conversation he said well do you
think I'm gonna get out of pain because
the surgeons I've I've said seen that
they said I'm done I'm not even gonna
get out of pain I've done so much damage
to my back and I said well I don't know
but let's let's that here's my best
effort and my best suggestion on what to
do well believe it or not he was out of
pain in about three weeks just learning
how to avoid the the triggers but he
said something very curious to me he
said well I'm gonna get out of pain and
when I get out of pain I want my world
record back and I said to him I said
well and obviously I'm a lot older than
he was and I said well if you were my
son Brian I'd give you this advice I
said let's work on getting you out of
pain but I I would seriously consider
doing something else with your life I
mean that this is a pretty compromise
spine to build you back to set a world
record again this but he said no I want
to do that and I said alright well if we
do it we'll write a book together so
that was the story behind the book
called the gift of injury he did get out
of pain he did own callosum which is you
stimulate the bone and he did things
like say a mildly loaded carry and he
would take five days off to allow the
scaffolding of the bone to occur the
adaptation that I described earlier
then he did that for a year so he bone
calloused for a year and then he started
to get back into training his strength
back again which he spent another year
or two doing and he came back and won
the Arnold's and then he came back and
won at the year again so I think he only
lifted what was at eleven hundred and
seventy four pounds something like that
then we showed the MRIs of his back
three years later once he'd been through
his l5 the first of all the fracture and
the sacrum had completely filled in l5
had remodeled under the chronic load and
it was square once again the disks were
looking pretty good I mean they weren't
flawless of course but anyway he has
zero pain is zero pain to this day and
he's still training and does the odd
competition and he's one of the old boys
on the block so we started writing the
book and I thought it was really going
to be his story sort of a very personal
story of triumph and all of that
well I we would write it together and I
found out he can write I had no idea and
as he wrote we couldn't stop we'd sit at
his kitchen Tate he was in Florida by
the way 2,000 miles away but I'd go down
and we we'd write for a bit and then
we'd go fish off his dock for a while
and have a beer and then we do some more
writing and eventually the thing got
done and then most lovely process of
writing a book go fishing have a beer
chill out barbecue write a bit more book
and then before you know you've made a
book that that was it but then we we I
don't want you to take this the wrong
way but we sort of fell in love with one
another now you know I you know what a
romantic well you know he's an
outstanding fella and he's just an ace
and we've become and and so often you
know if you get any clinical training at
all they teach you to don't get
emotionally involved with a patient
you know I cannot do that every single
patient I ever deal with I have to get
to the emotional level with them if
we're going to change their life this is
these are huge things
and anyway you know I become friends
with with I would say almost every
patient I ever see I need them to tell
and relate to me like they've never done
with anyone else before we've got to get
at the bottom of all of this anyway it
turned into a wonderful relationship and
then we couldn't stop writing so then
the book became a manual for strength
trainers or strength athletes regaining
their strength athleticism off of back
injury so it was a much thicker bigger
book than we ever expected so it's the
story plus a lot of the science and then
the programming at the end I do have a
copy of it no no I don't know okay well
I can send you a copy but anyway then as
I said we show the before and after em
ours of the Meccano stimulation that we
did that he did and readapted his back
so I think so hearing that story for me
the first time that I heard it was quite
a while ago on a podcast you did for
human OS and then we heard it again
during my research for this episode on
squirt University every time that I hear
that story of just how much damage was
done to Brian Carroll's bark and then
the level of competition that he wanted
to get himself back to and subsequently
did there's an unbelievable contrasting
effect with my injury which has been at
the forefront of my sort of training
mind for the last year and maybe for
many of the listeners as well they have
that particular niggle that particular
pain that back pain that just doesn't
seem to go away or doesn't seem to get
they get disheartened with their rehab
or it's not happening fast enough or why
is this particular injury being why is
this curse been given to me and me alone
why is this my trouble to my burden to
bear so to speak hearing that story of
just how
all bad Brian's back was when he arrived
to where he managed to get himself to is
for me incredibly inspirational not just
that it shows that it can be done and
stuff like that but just that he has the
mindset of a person who will be in a
situation where he's obliterated part of
his back and is going not only do I want
to get pain free but once I'm pain free
I'm I'm gonna go back and be better than
I ever was the this is the I love
hearing what you've just said because
this is the difference you were talking
earlier about that that one percenter
who becomes the world champion it's the
ones who are willing to endure when you
work with someone like Brian Carroll the
strength of character to basically put a
car on your back and then squat if
you're one millimeter out of line of
Drive you can't correct that you're
gonna get crushed so first of all to
have the strength of mind to to will
your body to do such a thing and you
know in history rehab and we've we've
worked together actually in rehabbing
some other champion power lifters sorry
these are patients who keep calling in
yeah if say you've got a power lifter
who wants to squat a thousand pounds
they've never done it before the first
part of it is conditioning their mind
that it's possible so what we'll do is
we'll take the target load say a
thousand pounds and we'll add 50 so
we'll put one thousand and fifty pounds
on their back and they do a one-inch
squat so already now the mind is there
they've handled it they know what it
feels like and then the physicality
takes over so it's such a game of mind
and physical adaptations neural
adaptations and all the rest of it it's
a really complicated enterprise that
that a lot of people don't don't
appreciate but there's a little bit of a
perspective on the character of a
person who can do that with their body
and then I carry it through all the way
to the end yeah yeah it's a it's a
really really fascinating story and I
love every time that I hear that story
about Brian absolute love I'm very very
excited to get stuck into the book as
well I why don't you have him on your
podcast you hear it from the horse's
mouth he's a he's a fabulous man and a
good storyteller and and he was doing
introducing Bradley of course absolutely
well listeners you've heard it here
first I might be speaking to Brian
Carroll sometime soon well not be ill
there'll be a cool second part I'm sure
Brian would love to his lovely fellow I
would love to hear where his mind's eye
again you know as some of the listeners
and I'm sure a lot of people will be
tuning in seeing your name is seeing the
particular topic that we're talking
about and thinking I want to hear I want
to frame my mind about injury in the
right way I want to have the mindset
which is going to be optimal to help me
progress my injury so one of the things
that the physio that's helping me with
my rehab says it's that making sure that
you're in the right mindset is a large
part of the battle that's huge yeah it's
huge you know but I'll just pick up on
that because in particular in your
country there are there there's been a
little bit of a transformation in
physical therapy where some if a person
comes in with back pain without even
assessing the patient they'll say oh
well your back isn't fragile you know to
just carry on and keep doing the
whatever it is you're doing and what I
say well hold on a second there are
different types of people if you get a
crossfitter and you say we'll just carry
on the person who's a crossfitter is a
go-getter to start with yeah and they
don't need to be encouraged to keep
going for it the breaks yes thank you
for the love of God pump the brakes
and but the next person who has this
idea well you know that they are
magnifying every little ache and pain
and you know they've had a good fart and
they're calling the doctor it's it's so
there's a time and a place to tell a
person yeah your back is fragile and for
a crossfitter you've got to hold them
back and a let biology adapt the
robustness to the tissues that you can't
see the fractures the micro fractures on
the MRI but they're there and it takes
time versus the next person who just is
a little bit more on the movement
adverse side of the spectrum yes you are
a little bit more robust than you think
let's let's prove it let's try a few
things and show them some good mechanics
once they've mastered the good mechanics
load them make sure the mechanics are
preserved and all of a sudden they've
just proven wow I'm training now I'm
pain free now I just have to organize
the progression in a way that isn't too
greedy
I'll respect the time process of the
adaptation and build them back so you
know it's different strokes for
different folks that's for sure yeah
I appreciate that you have athlete's
ringing you because you need to you need
to deal with some people who might be in
a little bit of back pain dr. McGill so
I'm I'm going to I'm gonna try and try
and call it there if there was one final
question that I had we've touched on it
already and you mentioned about stirring
the pot as one potential extra if you
were to have the next closest exercises
that were the closed runners up for the
big three were there any or would there
be any that your staple favorites for a
broad cross-section of athletes well I'm
not trying to avoid the question but of
course the answer depends on the
assessment and the person who's in front
of you are we talking about the American
record holder power lifter for men over
75 now
I just gave you a lot of information so
that would be an entirely different
program than it would be for you or I've
got a an olympic-class swimmer or you
know racecar driver it doesn't matter so
you see the answer is is very much a
moving target for myself for example I I
do some things well beyond the big three
that for my body at this stage in my
life I have zero pain I feel fabulous
I'm reasonably athletic for my age but
I've had a lot of trauma as well so what
I would do would be very different than
what you would do now this might
surprise some people whereas my body
would have thrived on more load and more
strength in my 30s 40s and maybe early
50s believe it or not now it's less load
and more mobility and you'll find that
people go through this progression so
two days a week now I work on things
that are a little bit stiff and stuck so
you know I've broken my neck I do a
little bit of neck work more stability
work not too much neck mobility but more
stability thoracic extension I'm turning
into a little old man so I have a little
bit more thoracic spine mobility through
my low back in former decades I would
have carried more load been more
cognizant of the perfect hip hinge now
I've backed right off on the load and I
get just a little bit more lumbar
mobility my hips yes a mobility
certainly leg strength and leg and hip
power is important as you get older the
most important thing is having the
ability to recover from a fall make sure
that if you stub your toe have hit power
to get your foot out in front of you to
arrest the fall these are the things
that will keep your life going for
a longer period of time anyway so do you
see how I have to give a context to this
and then I will give you the decades
honoring the past injury history etc to
come up with what the best progressions
beyond the big three would be but
there's a little bit of a start on the
discussion I got you dr. McGill I I
can't thank you enough for coming on
it's been absolutely fantastic
I'll make sure that links to back
mechanic the gift of injury and all of
the other resources that we've talked
about this evening will be in the show
notes below if you fire anything over an
email once we're done I'll make sure to
add that as well if there's any resource
well the books the books are on the
Amazon UK or amazon co dot uk' whatever
it is and but they're also on our
website back FitPro calm if people are
needlessly suffering with with their
their backs I understand
it's I'm absolutely certain they will
have helped a lot of people today if you
have any questions or any comments as
per usual feel free to get at me at
Criswell axe on all social media I'll
also make sure that dr. McGill's Twitter
is linked on there and if you want to
ask them on there and tweet things at
him and see if don't know we think that
it's no no I I don't I have a I have a
very strong conviction that if you're a
master of the craft you can't do
Facebook and Twitter there those two
don't go together
I don't know a master of the craft who
lives on social media so I don't do
social media however my daughter does
put up content but I have zero ability
to answer now I I do have an email but
that's as far as I'm going I'm afraid I
thought far too busy for fast well you
come from a similar cloth to us dr.
McGill it's it's one of those things
where I think a lot of people would
benefit from taking a more ascetic route
that that you have if you have things
that you want to be very good
in life social media is an antithesis of
pretty much everything as far as I'm
concerned so you know we're uh we're
part of the same camp but I'm gonna I'll
stop pontificating today's been great
dr. McGill thank you so much for your
time thanks Chris
[Music]